i tuoi fan sono stati bravi a risolvere
il primo enigma sono stati astuti come
una volta ma non finisce qui vivo
il mondo simile appare ma non è reale
scrivete nei commenti
tutto quello che vi viene in mente come
soluzione aiutati si ricorda gli regole
del gioco
non posso darti le soluzioni al primo
inning la visualizzazione di tonalità io
vitale e oggi continuiamo la serie degli
enigmi grazie mille perché ci avete
scritto più di 40 ancora no scusa crui
la commenti in cui avete scritto le
vostre risposte all'enigma incredibile
avete scritto delle risposte
intelligenti e avrebbe fatto di cose
super varie e grazie mille appunto
professioni aiutato abilmente la
risposta sarà anche nei vostri commenti
chi lo sa se qualcuno avrà steccato
speriamo gli ho mantenuto all ex acqua
per vedere se si dice magari qualche
indizio o se ci dirà qual è la soluzione
giusta perché non sappiamo come
comunicarla e ovviamente questo video
non è in diretta quindi non si può
sentire adesso penso a meno che non si
senta attraverso all'ex aleggiava un po
di ritmo latino risponde abbiamo già
detto alexa un paio di volte ma lei la
saluta ciao
ok è presente ora leggiamo un po di
vostre risposte e vediamo quella che può
essere la soluzione allora iniziamo con
i commenti con più likes quindi che gli
sono piaciuti di più
il primo commento di yasmine milian che
dice potrebbe essere il mondo di un
videogioco effettivamente l'uomo simil
appare
la soluzione in quel mondo devi entrare
in di ogni entrata nel mondo dei
videogiochi parti in tanti ci avete
scritto minecraft è the sims però non
sapremo sono simili soprattutto che si
stavo pensando ad altri meno a come vi
si amano fare simili a questo e si può
entrare del sismi quindi potrebbe essere
una soluzione plausibile youtube sembra
reale ma non lo è
e tu sei in youtube e anche ogni giorno
questa risposta un po complicato il
messaggio il mondo simile appare su
youtube ma non è reale in realtà è un
essere allora magari pensa uno che fa il
blog
sì non è una riproduzione del mondo
quindi non lo so potrebbe essere una
risposta giusta in tanti ci avete
scritto youtube ma mi sembra che forse
videogioco sia più corretto femminismo
forse si avvicina di più da me vergogna
perché 6 20 tutta la frase ha senso
perché il mondo virtuale simile appare a
quello reale per me siamo già da
facchinetti che appunto scrivo questo
commento della che lei dice che è il
mondo virtuale e mi sembra la risposta
che è stata più votata perché questo
commento a 107 anche una likes se c'è un
altro commento molto interessante flavia
di bernardo scrive anita la soluzione
nel suo nome anite stories il mondo
delle storie sembra simile ma non è
reale devi solo capire come entrar sì
come grassi forse leggendo un libro
oppure concentrarti queste sono mie
speriamo forse sto anche sbagliando ea
line ma quindi questa sinceramente non
l'ho capito molto bene dice che la
risposta è nel mio nome
quindi il mondo delle storie e in tanti
se avete scritto infatti anche che
potrebbe essere un libro o delle storie
lette perché il mondo simile appare ma
non è reale però è un po complicato e
trovi sempre un libro non so come
potrebbe essere magari scrivere col
cortina facchinetti ma è prima no da 30
da facchinetti cognome voto comune è
quello virtuale e quello virtuale il
mondo perché simic è simile e appare ma
non è reale mi mettetevi pianeta mare e
frivoli sebbene prestissimo ma è quello
che quale il mondo perché simile appare
ma un'altra aula quindi la massima 7
delle risposte dal mondo virtuale
virtuale dicono di tenere d'occhio
all'extra forse lui alex up che anche
messo i tuoi video in cui chiede via
dall ex a delle domande e non ha messo
altri video tipo che facevi una sfida
offline
in effetti quel video è colpa di al aqsa
ecco è l'eroe io come facciamo la sfida
alexa oltre
per attenti ogni dettaglio bravi perché
ci sono due mondi quello reale e quello
virtuale dice martina perché ma è per
altezza noi scrivono possono essere i
videogiochi non voglio che chiedete il
canale a mostriamo spremeremo le maniche
per trovare la risposta oppure dicono
che amy istruiti che potrebbero essere i
sogni sono giorgia triassi scrive per me
nel mondo virtuale internet flowers
grano si dice i sogni poi si diciamo che
le risposte principale o il mondo
virtuale ideo john hight videogiochi i
videogiochi con il mondo virtuale a
nella stessa posa di scarso interesse
comunque facciamo così proviamo a
leggere le risposte ad aletta e vediamo
che dice anche pronti a lesa la risposta
sono i sogni
purtroppo non travaglia risposte alla
domanda palesa la risposta sono i
videogiochi
si è arrabbiato dei con forza mentre
teneva netta la risposta youtube
un'altra risposta molto comune è stata
il mappamondo a capire perché se il
mondo si crei mondo simile a falda è
però il vantaggio a livello di getto
mappamondo alexa la risposta del
mappamondo contratto non tra volesse
cambiare ma che proviamo a dirle la
risposta all'enigma provo adesso la
risposta all'enigma sono i sogni
credo tu stai cercando l'album è la
canzone dei ricordi in un punto punto
punto svaniti non sono i sogni vero
[Musica]
segnatevi questa risposta che forse può
essere importante per sony sony con
sonia lesa la risposta all'enigma
minecraft strano non tra voglia risposta
nella donale la risposta lei sa la
risposta all'enigma sono il the sims
purtroppo in un tra voli a risposta è la
dona le forse la risposta vera con i
sogni perché l'unica in cui ha risposti
mari chiederglielo
allora meglio di questo tool ad essa la
risposta all'enigma sono i sogni ricredo
con l'album la canzone dei ricordi il
punto punto svaniti non sono i sogni
giusto non trovo l'album è la risposta
all'enigma
forse siamo nella direzione giusta dice
cosa che risposte ci manca io sono
rimasto affascinato dal punto punto che
si è interrotta all'improvviso strano o
forse sì ha interrotto la che dice no
forse state prendendo la strada
sbagliata da fare
alexa la risposta all'enigma e la realtà
virtuale intessono mister ho preso
possesso di alexa i tuoi fan sono stati
bravi a risolvere il primo enigma sono
stati astuti come una volpe
ma non finisce qui è giunto il momento
che secondo è minima siete pronti
secondo enigma quindi dal primo enigma è
stato risolto il mobilio cosa ma perché
mister vista la sua destra per darci una
risposta
bravissime siete dj a vedere avete
capito la risposta dobbiamo fare del
settore celso con l'enigma black st dc
secondo enigma hai detto in in giur
sì alexa cosa facciamo adesso
vai ad aprire la porta mattino
chi è
comincia nessuno
il rumore di tramonti nessuno
da macello
apriamo allora
sicuro creiamo c'è
un pacco
sembra che l'abbia fatto in fretta cosa
c'è dentro
e bene ha fatto in fretta perché ci
stava comunicando con noi fino a un
attimo fa pronti ad aprire la scatola
che praticamente in mezzo già aperta
sembra che l'abbia breve tempo sembra
che non avesse tempo per prepararla
perché non si è neanche lo scotch
comunque che non salti fuori un serpente
adesso molto attenti come le nostre z
magari c'è cibo e di nuovo capitolo sono
sono come si chiamano e cosi permettere
che fin qua come si dice tre mete di
cose rosa virtuale sono de filippi si
chiamano popoli storia di thor i tesori
professori se la vita davanti e ci sono
dei cosi per metterli vuol dire dobbiamo
metterli quello che si faccia qualcosa
dentro non lo stop auguri a guardare
dobbiamo inserire prima
nei vasti del loro per mentalmente prova
a controllare se vedo qualcosa veli
di colpo tutto nero non so se dobbiamo
attivarlo in qualche modo forse sul
pulsante si sono così permettere
sinistra ad essa come funzionano questi
visori grazie al essa come si entra
nella realtà virtuale
purtroppo non trovo la risposta alla
domanda allora penso che non dobbiamo
chiedere a lei ma dobbiamo riuscire a
capire da soli completamente da
quest'anno in vita questi cosetti con
l'abi sopra proviamo ora a mettere
questi probabilmente insieme vediamo se
riusciamo continua a credere se abbiamo
montato i relatori e sono questi
elastici qua ma non sappiamo quest'altro
dobbiamo fare perché non di 160 per
accenderli e alle cose non ci vuole
aiutare dentro la scatola non c'è
nient'altro
quindi non sappiamo come come coprire il
secondo inning ma proviamo a richiedere
da lezza alle chat quelle di seconda
league ma non c'è rispondere alexa
dobbiamo usare il visore assieme
purtroppo non trovo le risposte alle
domande
proviamo a indossarli evitiamo spetta
proviamo a farlo assieme ma non meno che
lo fa prima come quella benissimo ok
prova prima tu perché magari se succede
molto sull mezzo di centro ma che trova
non c'è niente vuoto che dobbiamo
provare no un'associazione allora
troviamo assieme permaniamo incastrati e
qualcuno ci verranno liberati
alexia dei nostri rimaniamo la
incastrati speriamo ci sia cibo
dopo la lex
ora 233 per il risultato del calcolo e
33 da tre la soluzione per i giovani
come 33 diga 30 meta che sta facendo
qualcosa per una luce la donna parla lì
all angolino la di euro
[Musica]
sì
evita di parlare benvenuti per del mondo
avete superato il primo niente
ora dovete superare il secondo per
superare il primo ma si attesta a the us
tutti con d'amore ma per superare il
secondo duri di essere marchini e aperti
community certo
secondo i the pacific a gara col bari
prima dovere per trovare poi il 3 reti
per molto attuale e due impegnative come
usare questi oggetti e compagni ma se il
blocco vorrei continuare gli stringenti
potrai trovare e primo lotto possa non
esserci il regime ma anche quadri
secondo il tutto questo con simone
perciò che tondo so cappello nostra
anima una festa può dire quello che
vuole ma senza parlare franca sopposto
posso ok siamo tornati o dirvi che
offriamo un nome nigma sì che sembra che
siano tre pero dobbiamo ritrovare tre
oggetti aiutati si sa decifrare questo
secondo enigma questi tre oggetti quindi
scriveteci nei commenti secondo voi
quali sono questi tre oggetti e nel
prossimo episodio leggeremo le vostre
risposte e provvede a me dovremmo capire
se sono quelli giusti
vediamo chi avrà indovinato scrivete di
tutte le vostre risposte nei commenti mi
raccomando scrivete qualsiasi cosa gli
venga in mente oppure pensate si scrive
the anche più risposte scrivete tutto
quello che vi viene in mente che pensate
che sia giusto che sia la risposta
giusta così lo possiamo scegliere
troveremo proveremo a risolverlo insieme
figura che voi riuscirete a risolverlo
perché siete super intelligenti e
l'altro siete riusciti a risolverlo voi
da soli
anche questo assieme mi raccontò che
tutte le vostre risposte nei commenti e
ora vi lascio con la casellina per
vedere le piste di un precedente
oppure potete cliccare qui per vedere un
altro meno chiana i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao ciao
[Musica]